[Musique]
tous les soirs quand tu rentres chez toi
mater youtube sur ton écran plat la
suite dépend de ta personnalité soit tu
vas et tu es ou bien likez
lalalalalalalalala
lalanne lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala lalala le hunter picon tumeur il
sert à rien il parle comme un chien ses
tripes à lui ses dix liquette e montée
c'est un d'enfoirés il a souvent
pas de gel
youtube pour lui préfère stastiques est
sûr être dans le même genre il ya le
troll il insultait trouve ça trop lol il
n'hésite pas non plus à 10 leaké
évidemment toi ça te fait trop chier
enfin bref ces gars sont super chiant
ils sont lourds et ce pendant 10 ans
tous les soirs quand tu rentres chez toi
ma paye ou tu sur ton écran plein la
suite dépend de ta personnalité soit tu
vas et tu es ou bien likez lalala lalala
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala lalala lalala lalala
[Musique]
maintenant passons aux mecs qu'on adore
c'est vraiment un abonné en un
[Musique]
il va mater d'autres des vidéos et
pourra te dire si c est en revanche si
il voudrait te le dis
rire d'eux-mêmes
il ira même jusqu'à samedi
ce mec là est vraiment on post il est où
dispose dans ses abonnements
franchement ça c'est vraiment trop
dément
du nouveau à chaque connexion
ouais plus qu'un mettre le son
nous avons
tous les soirs quand tu rentres chez toi
mater youtube sur ton écran plat
regardez tout ce qu'il vient de sortir
oh oui tout ça te fait vraiment plaisir
lalala lalala lalala
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala lalala la suite ce gars
complètement fan l'on dirait qu'il veut
que tu sois sa fin ils pensent que
youtube eux c'est msn il veut te voir
même dans des endroits obscène
alors il va vraiment pas lâché jusqu'à
ce que tu veux bien discuter
et quand ce jour-là arrivera eh ben ce
gars lève les bras
il appellera tous ses potes pour dire
que ce soir il va pas très bien dormi
un les gars je lui ai parlé
je suis trop content voire même presque
gay
tous les soirs quand tu rentres chez toi
mattéï où tu sur ton écran plat la suite
dépend de ta personnalité soit tu vas et
tu es ou bien like et tous les soirs
quand tu rentres chez toi mater youtube
sur ton écran plat regardez tous ceux
qu'il vient de sortir oh oui tout ça se
fait vraiment plaisir
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala
[Musique]
mandat public et pouvoir maintenant clé
il faut cliquer monsieur numérique
pourquoi on tue la pause